[Música]
las sesiones diplomáticas entre Francia
y burkina burkina faso están en uno de
sus puntos más álgidos esta semana el
país africano decidió retirar las tropas
francesas que están en su territorio
para combatir al yihadismo con lo que
acaba un acuerdo militar que pactaron en
2018 Francia respondió llamado a
consultas a su embajador en la capital
huagadum Luke alad así se debilita la
presencia militar de Francia en el sahel
estas son una subregión del norte de
África que abarca territorios de 11
países desde mauritania hasta eritrea
como lo vemos en el mapa y donde Francia
tiene por ahora a tres mil de sus
militares que combaten contra grupos
vinculados al qaeda y a la
autodenominado estado islámico
especialmente en níger chat y
precisamente burkina faso para hablar de
este tema nos acompaña Vivi
investigadora visitante Junior del
Barcelona centerford International of
First Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí Vivian en Francia 24 y buenas
tardes para usted en España esta
decisión llega a menos de cinco meses
después del golpe de estado en burkina
faso ahora liderado por Ibrahim traoré y
en un repunte tanto de la inseguridad
como de la impopularidad de Francia en
el país africano en ese contexto
explíquenos por favor Cuáles son las
razones por las que deciden retirar a
las tropas francesas
primero buenos buenos días y muchas
gracias por invitarnos es importante
entender que no hay una opinión y fue
uniforme entre las personas expertas
pero para mí las que los motivos de pez
que tienen más peso es por una parte el
acercamiento a Rusia los países del
están tratando de diversificar
sus opciones Y en este caso Francia no
va a colaborar con aquellos países que
tengan tropas de Wagner en su territorio
también una reafirmación de la soberanía
nacional es importante también saber que
una fase es un país que de forma
histórica con el legado de ankara
siempre hace ejercicios de reafirmación
y ahora estamos en un contexto
de ruptura política por decirlo de
alguna manera en la que se están
tratando de deshacer de muchos de los
símbolos del colonialismo no también
bueno i̇brahim traoré dio un golpe de
estado hace hace pocos meses no y
teniendo en cuenta que la opinión
pública en parte les sustentaba por su
tendencia anti francesa también podría
ser una razón de peso el mantenimiento
de la opinión pública el tenerles
contentos sabiendo que la presencia de
tropas galas no es bienvenida también es
decir que es importante saber que macron
desde el Eliseo ha planteado que
es probable que
esta decisión no sea unánime y que se
haya utilizado la salida de Ibrahim
traurea una expedición militar para
comunicarla por lo que pide
pide que haya una aclaración por parte
de del jefe de la junta militar
lo que por otro lado se plantea que
puede ser una estrategia para ganar
tiempo y precisamente hablando de este
tiempo que se quiere ganar una de las
grandes dudas es cuando se finalizará la
presencia de las tropas francesas en
burkina faso algunos informes
extraoficiales dice que esto será entre
finales de febrero y principios de abril
Pero qué se conoce sobre esa fecha de
salida y sobre todo
Serán las implicaciones para la
seguridad del país africano
Pues no hay una una decisión una
decisión Clara Por una parte el
comunicado planteaba una salida de un
mes mientras que los acuerdos de defensa
planteaban que tras la finalización del
acuerdo habrían dos meses de salida por
lo tanto es probable que la fecha exacta
de esta o sea de esta de esta salida
vaya a ser negociada entre los dos
gobiernos sobre el contexto de seguridad
es difícil de predecir en una situación
de tantísima fragilidad y un contexto
tan volátil la operación que Francia
tiene en burkina faso no es la operación
barcán no ha sido la operación sabré que
no es una operación que haya estado
trabajando de forma intensiva como ha
sido en los casos de mal y níger con las
fuerzas armadas de burkina faso por lo
tanto por ejemplo algunos de los
informantes que tengo en terreno
están tranquilos y la población de hecho
pide la entrada de Rusia Entonces se
plantea que las tropas de Wagner que
vayan a poder sustituir el trabajo que
sí que ha podido estar haciendo en
Francia luchando contra El terrorismo
bueno y usted menciona reiteradamente
dos elementos primero esta fuerza
anticolonialista que surge y que crece
cada vez más en países africanos como
burkina faso dos la cercanía a nuevos
aliados como Rusia Especialmente con las
milicias Wagner que son cercanas al
kremlin Algo similar pasó en mal y el
año pasado cuando el país africano
decidió sacar a las tropas francesas sin
embargo hay una leve diferencia Y es que
en burkina faso la presencia de
yihadismo es mucho más fuerte que Mali
usted qué similitudes y qué diferencias
ve entre las comparaciones de
maliburquera
Es una muy buena pregunta sí que es
cierto que en ambos países se han dado
golpes de estado de hecho golpes de
estado también dentro de golpes de
estado siguen un patrón muy similar hay
un crecimiento del sentimiento ante
francés muy fuerte en el que asocian a
Francia con el crecimiento en parte de
del yihadismo hay muchísima
desinformación ambos países comparten
una historia burkina faso más pero vamos
países comparten una historia donde ha
habido tintes revolucionarios de
socialismo y anticolonialidad pero la
diferencia es que el Mali ha habido un
crecimiento de tensiones diplomáticas
previo a la ruptura de relaciones de la
salida de Los Embajadores de ambos
países a La retirada de de las tropas
francesas del país ha habido sanciones
apoyadas fuertemente por Francia que han
tenido un impacto económico en el
territorio mientras que en burkina faso
esta situación no se ha dado no decir
burkina faso toma una decisión con una
cierta frialdad lo que es muy
interesante porque podría denotar que
que hay un efecto dominó no solamente es
burkina faso el país que
está viendo como los flotantes van a
abandonar sus tropas sino que también lo
estamos viendo en República
centroafricana en zimbabue de una manera
diferente Que
incluso con el una invitación de los
Estados Unidos para participar en una
cumbre de Estados después de muchos años
en relaciones
decidió hacer una apuesta fuerte por por
Rusia no Entonces sí que lo que lo que
estamos viendo Es que hay un cambio
geopolítico mayor y la preocupación es
es burkina
los últimos vamos a ver nuevas
solicitudes de retirada de tropas en los
próximos meses muy bien y como usted lo
mencionó Esta no es la operación con la
que Francia estuvo durante tantos años
en el sahel para combatir
sin embargo si se disminuye la presencia
francesa en esta región africana además
al sumarse a Mali cuéntenos Qué opciones
militares le queda entonces a Francia y
por qué su interés de estar militarmente
en esta zona
en Francia tiene mucho interés en
mantener la estabilidad de la zona
porque lo que implica que hay
inestabilidad hay mayor flujo y presión
migratoria hacia Europa también porque
Francia como con la gran historia que
tiene con la región mantiene
infraestructura crítica mantiene en
muchos
ciudadanos franceses A los que tiene que
proteger y no quiere que haya una un
avance de la inestabilidad hacia el
propio suelo europeo no que se puedan
dar más ataques yihadistas en suelo
europeo también bueno Francia
cuenta con con la influencia en África y
el activismo diplomático para tener un
rol más importante en la comunidad
internacional por lo que sí que dejara
de representar a los Estados franceses
de esta forma Pues también caería su
propia capacidad de influencia No pero
en todo caso Francia va a seguir estando
en la región Francia Sigue estando en
níger Sigue estando en chat y se plantea
que es probable que estos efectivos
vayan a dirigirse hacia allí y luego
también
bueno estas se están firmando una serie
de acuerdos en todo el golfo de Guinea
donde también podrían dirigirse estos
militares por el auge de la piratería en
la región